[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
à pour le sommaire course à pied le
premier semi marathon le trap et étant
réalisée ce dimanche avec au programme
20 % de route et 80% de parcours en
pleine nature solide de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines un peu plus de 150
participants souffert sur le tracé tous
les détails de cette huile sport
ultimate le club zéro gènes de plaisir
organisé ce week-end la 14e édition de
son tournoi en ligne de rebaptiser 0
peine au rendez vous a réuni douze
équipes spécialiste du lancer de frisbee
venus de toute la région ile de france
plus de renseignements à suivre basket
nous regardons sur l'excellente saison
du club de trappes dans le championnat
de nationale 3 les joueurs de l'ancien
basketteur de l'équipe de france ti de
tchicamboud termine à une très belle
quatrième place où nous recevrons le
président et le capitaine dans ce
magazine
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département
[Musique]
je le disais dans les titres le premier
semi-marathon de trappes était organisée
ce dimanche 15 avril entre le gymnase de
guimier l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
un parcours inédit imaginé à 80% en
pleine nature et qui attire et 168 à
courageux des images de nicolas kirilow
800 avantages et jules de greling ville
une grande première à trappes la ville a
organisé ce dimanche 15 avril son tout
premier semi marathon
un rendez-vous dans les cadavres depuis
de nombreux mois on a on avait un besoin
un an qui existait sur cette ville c'est
que les trappistes couraient tous
individuellement mais ne se retrouver
jamais ensemble pour une course unique
donc on a choisi de l'organiser cette
année elle répond à un vrai besoin
ce dimanche ils étaient 168 inscrits au
départ les coureurs en débuté par deux
kilomètres en zone urbaine avant de
s'engouffrer dans l'île de loisirs un
secteur qui représentait 80% du parcours
on profite vraiment d'un cadre
exceptionnel avec lille de loisirs
beaucoup de coureurs spontanément
attrapé dans les environs viennent
courir sur l'île de loisirs donc ils
connaissent le cadre est franchement
profiter du bruit des oiseaux de la
musique de l'île de loisirs qui si
singulière de l'aspect nature de cette
course c'est un bénéfice dont on va
profiter à fond sur la ligne d'arrivée
younès il del moudden du club d'evreux a
emporté cette première épreuve le
coureur a dompté les 21 km du parcours
en 1h 10 minutes et 27 secondes qu'on
puisse aider beaucoup
la forêt a pas de coups de la russe ils
devront aussi mais je réalise le primat
du kilomètre mais après 15 kilomètres
j'étais corps mais j'ai fini
un tranquille et j'ai gagné vu le succès
rencontré cette année une nouvelle
édition devrait être à nouveau organisé
sur trappe en 2019
on continue sur cette fuite sport part
du rugby le championnat de fédérale 2
c'est désormais officiel après sa
victoire contre domont le 8 avril
dernier plaisir est maintenu avec ses 15
points d'avancé sur le premier relégable
arras résultat qui permet déjà plaisir
de se projeter sur la saison prochaine
pour nous parler du club nous recevons
sur ce plateau le coach de l'équipe
sébastien roncalli sébastien quel est
votre sentiment après ce matin en bas
beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir bien sûr on
est très très heureux d'avoir pu
atteindre l'objectif qui était du
maintien exactement et en plus on finit
vraiment positivement la saison
puisqu'on arrive à accrocher les gros
bond chez nous on arrive à faire de bons
résultats
balade au mont voilà donc je suis très
très heureux très satisfait de ce
résultat et du travail accompli par tout
le staff vous l'avez bien fêter avec vos
joueurs
oui bien sûr veut on a bien fêté après
il nous reste encore un match dimanche
si on veut vraiment finir positivement
l'année donc on a prévu vraiment de
faire une belle soirée dimanche soir se
maintient ou semble logique vous avez su
gagner contre vos concurrents directs
arras et d'hautmont lors du dernier
match vous a émis un sanglant 54 à 7 à
domont finalement vous étiez plus fort
que ces deux équipes
oui je pense oui très sincèrement sur le
sur le terrain il n'y a pas eu y a pas
eu photo cette année je pense qu'on
était
on était beaucoup mieux préparés que
ouais et collectivement on a on a on a
pu proposer quand même un autre style de
rugby qui a fini par payer sur la fin de
saison
votre effectif était plus fort oui je
pense oui oui après
voilà nous on a quelques soucis en terme
de densité
voilà c c'est un peu ce qui nous manque
mais collectivement
je pense qu'on était vraiment plus fort
que densité vous voulez dire
physiquement physique densité physique
rond on souffre pas mal cette année oui
alors le maintien c'était l'objectif
fixé en début de saison vous disiez a
précédemment avez vous douté à un moment
donné quand début la saison ça
fonctionnait pas forcément comme vous
l'espériez vous avez remporté votre
première victoire lors de la 5e journée
le 22 octobre est un mois après le début
de la compétition
oui vous n'avez pas douté non à aucun
moment on n'a aucun moment on a on a
vraiment travaillé toute l'année sans
aucune pression et
voilà même s'il y avait effectivement
cet objectif voilà on l'a travaillé
sereinement et on savait que ce serait
difficile les premières défaites on a
joué 2 face à des grosses grosses
écuries qui ont un budget qui est
surdimensionné par rapport aux nôtres
donc forcément pas les mêmes atouts sur
le terrain voilà on avait un groupe qui
était un peu diminué par rapport à
l'année dernière donc je pense que c'est
une vraie belle performance ce que les
joueurs ont réalisé cette année c'était
au discours avant le début du
championnat de ne pas forcément
s'affoler sur les premières défaites
oui tout à fait et puis surtout de de
jouer sans aucune appréhension sans
aucun sentiment d'infériorité
parce que c'est des garçons qui ont joué
étant jeunes à des plus haut niveau et
qu'ils méritent leur place actuellement
fédérale 2 et qui je pense ont encore
une belle marge de progression
psychologiquement comment on gère à un
groupe qui doit finalement s'imposer sur
quatre matches comment on les garde
concentré tout au long de la saison
effectivement on a ciblé certaines
rencontres
qui était capitale pour nous donc et que
ces objectifs-là qui était qui étaient
primordiaux à atteindre
les mecs se sont ré recentrer sur ses
objectifs là sans non plus laisser les
autres matches deux côtés on a bossé sur
toutes les rencontres
voilà maintenant avec nos armes donc on
sait on sait très bien qu'on a encore du
travail à accomplir mais quelles que
soient les matches pendant les garçons
jamais baissé les bras on s'est jamais
affolé on a toujours travaillé et je
pense qu'une fois de plus sur le ce
qu'on peut réaliser sur la fin de saison
on montre qu'on a notre place avec la
différence n'est pas si grande que ça à
l'arrivée il y a toujours eu l'espoir
d'accrocher un gros oui tout à fait
bajeux là j'avais bon espoir ya quinze
jours de battre leurs oeufs qui est 5e
de poule à la maison on a perdu deux
points on les a accrochés là on finit
par chartres qui est bien placé aussi au
classement et l'objectif c'est vraiment
de gagner dimanche quoi avec ce match
contre chartres donc est programmée ce
dimanche 22 avril
vous préparez déjà la saison prochaine
oui oui bien sûr ça fait déjà un mois et
demi qu'on est con et tournées sur
différents objectifs sur la préparation
de l'année prochaine
là où on est très contents aussi cette
année c'est qu'on a une équipe qui peut
jouer la qualification dimanche
donc si ils arrivent à gagner ils
pourront jouer les phases finales donc
on prolongera un peu la saison au sein
de notre groupe seniors même si ce n'est
pas l'équipe fanion c'est très important
pour nous parce qu'ils ont joué un rôle
très important donc cette année certains
joueurs jouent leur place ce dimanche
pour l'année prochaine non non vous
n'avez pas les juger sur un match
non non pas du tout non pas du tout pas
du tout toute l'année on a pris en
compte des facteurs d'absence des
problèmes de travail problème de soucis
familiaux enfin bon comme ça doit
arriver dans la vie au quotidien sont
des choses qu'on doit gérer nous comme
un club 100% amateur est pareil sur les
grosses écuries
ils sont pratiquement professionnels
donc voilà c'est pas la même gestion et
on a eu affaire à ça toute l'année et on
prend en compte tous ces facteurs là
bien sûr
est ce que vous serez le coach le
plaisir la saison prochaine oui oui
entre autres oui je serai un plaisir
l'année prochaine
vous travaillez déjà sur le recrutement
du coup oui tout à fait vrai on est sur
plusieurs plusieurs joueurs en contact
déjà on en a besoin quel poste par
exemple notamment poste de dix postes de
première ligne qui est très très
important sur lequel on est on est très
léger du seconde ligne et aussi quelques
trois quarts au centre notamment combien
de joueurs ont tous vous avez un essai y
développe deux joueurs ouais on a ciblé
pour l'instant six joueurs
voilà ce qui à notre niveau est déjà
conséquent ce qui représente quasiment
50 % d'effectifs titulaires
[Musique]
non c'est à dire c'est à dire si six
joueurs sur 15 vous allez vous avez
changé l'équipe titulaire de six joueurs
sur 15 ha non non c'est du recrutement
là également pour le banc et les gars
qu'on recrute n'ont aucune assurance de
titulaire d'entrée de jeu l'année
prochaine comme ça ça se passera sur le
terrain
voilà le maintien ça sera l'objectif
également la saison prochaine ouais bien
sûr le maintien et puis surtout avoir un
peu plus d'ambition et puis a évolué
déjà dans un milieu de tableau je pense
que c'est la suite logique des choses
voilà maintenant effectivement on va pas
mettre la charrue avant les boeufs comme
on dit et on essaie déjà de préserver
notre groupe en place veut garder tout
le monde de renforcer par quelques
touches pour éventuellement avoir un
meilleur résultat et prochain en tout
cas c'est l'ambition du club de de jouer
à un très bon niveau en fédérale 2 merci
à vous sébastien khalid est passé sur ce
plateau si vous voulez voir une dernière
fois appelé plaisir aux à domicile et
pour fêter avec les joueurs le maintien
de l'équipe en fédérale 2 la rencontre
entre contre chartres est programmée ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade robert
barran on continue par un résultat de
rugby en match en retard de division
honneur le sky termine sa saison par une
superbe victoire 20 à 19 sur son terrain
contre le troisième vincennes ce
dimanche
un résultat qui permet aux joueurs de
thomas payen promu cette saison de
terminer à une très belle 6e place avec
un bilan de 7 victoires 1 nuls et 10
défaites
l'objectif du club a été atteint un
sport en sport américain ou un sport aux
accents américains étaient à l'honneur
ce week-end est empli de l'encours jouer
leur septième match de la saison dans le
championnat de football américain
les élans courte en ont pris une
sérieuse option sur les playoffs de
deuxième division après leur victoire 27
à 0 face aux vikings de villeneuve
d'ascq résultat qui leur permet
d'occuper la deuxième place prochain
match le samedi 28 avril sur le terrain
du leader à les spartiates d'amiens
or handball très mauvaise opération pour
le 2ème plaisir les joueurs de victor
garrigues et se sont inclinés ce
week-end sur le terrain de stella sport
sa mort à l'occasion de la 16e journée
de nationale 3 le score 29 à 27 une
défaite qui pourrait priver les plaisirs
aura d'une accession nationale 2 les
plaisirs wa voir revenir le troisième
marolles à un petit point et massy à
deux points prochain match dimanche
prochain à domicile contre saint bandry
un mode ultimate à présent le club
zéro gènes de plaisir a organisé ce
week-end la 14e édition de son tournoi
en indoor baptisé à 0 peine
le rendez vous a réuni douze équipes
spécialiste du lancer de frisbee et
venues de toute la région ile de france
les images de nicolas à kirill house les
joueurs de l'équipe amour du disque
peuvent savourer les roses viennent de
remporter le 14e 0.2 plaisir l'un des
plus grands tournois indoor d'ultimate
en ile de france
c'était un match très intense très fair
play et qu'ils gagnent à la fin de
justesse donc on est super contents
c'est un tournoi qu'on aime bien faire
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on fait on
était là lors de la première édition
et puis on essaie de faire chaque année
dont quand on a la chance d'être pris ça
avec grand plaisir que on honore notre
sélection depuis 1997 le rendez vous
organisé par le club zéro gènes de
plaisir prend de l'ampleur cette année
le tournoi amical est passé de huit à
douze équipes venues de la région
francilienne
et pour la première fois la centaine de
joueurs présents s'est affrontés sur
deux gymnases au palais des sports et
sur nicholas leur certains joueurs font
leur première expérience aux européennes
c'est un tournoi qui se renouvelle
avec des nouveaux joueurs chaque année
et puis oui l'ultimate en france grandi
prend de l'ampleur avec différents
championnats que ce soit en salle ou en
extérieur ou sur plage c'est une
pratique c'est un sport en développement
dont on apprécie le zéro pm reviendra
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition le club zéro je n'aurais en 2019
deux objectifs faire grandir encore un
peu plus au rendez vous et tentez de
remporter le tournoi pour la première
fois de son histoire
on ouvre une page football dans ce set 8
sport dans le championnat de première
division de district monti le bretonneux
s'est imposé 1 à 0 contre l'épaule et
revient à un point du premier non
relégable
ouille vos repas s'est incliné 4 à 3
face aux chaînés redescend la quatrième
place vu en cours s'incline contre le fc
mantois 1 à 0 dans les autres rencontres
les clayes-sous-bois se fend corrigé 3 0
par le leader les mureaux et occupe
toujours la dernière place du
championnat
le pecs s'impose 2 0 contre ou enfin à
gargenville s'impose 3 à 2 sur le
terrain à atteindre et court on prend
maintenant la direction de
mantes-la-jolie la fondation psg a
inauguré à ce jeudi 12 avril la première
école rouge et bleu du département la
deuxième sur le territoire français dans
le quartier du val fourré la structure
accueille depuis le 9 avril dernier 128
enfants de 7 à 11 en échec scolaire
après les cours
objectif leur donner envie à d'apprendre
pour cela les jeunes sont encadrés par
des éducateurs de la fondation psg
écoles comprend également un stade et un
terrain synthétique on écoute la joueuse
de l'équipe de france et du psg à leur
boulot présente au jour de l'événement
avec adrien radio et nasser el rey life
is a eu des moments d'échangés avec les
enfants qui étaient top
je pense que c'est un super projet qui a
déjà montré que ça que ça fonctionne et
dans la première école qui avait été
ouverte
voilà si les valeurs du sport peuvent
aider tous ces jeunes avaient à
s'épanouir et à réussir dans leur vie
c'est mission accomplie et nous on était
là un peu avec adrien radio pour marquer
le coup et
aussi les inspirer après le football on
poursuit par du basket le club de
trappes s'est très largement imposée ce
samedi soir contre caen le score est
sans appel 115,66 face à une équipe du
haut de tableau
un résultat qui permet aux trappistes de
terminer la saison à la quatrième place
pour nous parler de ces très bons
résultats
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président jacques michel et le capitaine
de l'équipe de trappes et lionel laout
soft bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va tout d'abord revenir sur
cette très large oui victoire acquise ce
week-end qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence
vous étiez en feu c'était surtout
c'était surtout envie j'ai l'impression
et l'osmose en fait dans les villes qui
sévit ces produits tout au tout au long
de la saison qui a fait que voilà samedi
c'était l'apothéose et tout rentrait cet
ancien à 66 contre la troisième équipe
du place du classement exactement
ben en fait c'est un peu le ce qui est
un peu frustrant cette saison c'est que
on a abattu toutes les premières équipes
enfin la première et la deuxième équipe
la deuxième équipe on les a battus en
aller retour
la troisième équipe on vient d iliad les
enfants c'est chez nous
c'est ce qui a fait un peu que la saison
était avec des hauts et des bas en fait
président vous aviez augmenter la prime
pour ce match impossible une prime
schipper donnons la prime que nous avons
c'est celle en fait du plaisir d'être
ensemble le plaisir également d'avoir
progressé je crois que cette équipe a au
delà des progrès techniques à réaliser
quelque chose qui est bien plus délicat
à réviser c'est la confiance et l'estimé
de soi et la confiance et d'estimé dans
les autres et c'est vraiment d'ailleurs
la base de notre projet tout entier par
cette plante dont l'équipe
voilà et je crois que nous sommes
effectivement arrivé à 7 à cet excellent
résultat parce que les joueurs aiment
bien être ensemble ils ont appris à bien
jouer ensemble et ils ont une relation
alors à leur taux de change qui tout à
fait remarquable
c'est une victoire qui permet de se
mettre en confiance pour la saison
prochaine ouais c'est sûr ça va nous
permettre d'y penser déjà
oui bien sûr c'est dans les têtes de
tout le monde
on voulait vraiment finir en beauté
cette saison comme en début de saison il
ya eu beaucoup de remaniements dans
l'équipe par rapport à l'année dernière
l'osmose a mis un peu de temps là la
mayonnaise a mis un peu de temps à se
mettre en place mais une fois que ça a
été mis en place
voilà enfin samedi les supporters ont
été ravis a eu des spectacles et des
dunks c'était c'était fantastique
je vais qualifier votre saison de très
bonnes est ce que vous n'avez pas quand
même quelques regrets
finalement quand on voit un résultat
comme celui là ben voilà justement ces
quatrièmes c'est vrai que ça fait un peu
une petite frustration parce qu'on se
dit qu'on aurait vraiment eu
on avait vraiment l'occasion d'être à la
première place et d'être montée en
nationale 2 cette saison mais il ya eu
beaucoup de choses des beaucoup de
blessures aussi cette saison qui ont
fait que notre l'un de nos demeures
s'est blessé pendant quatre mois il ya
eu des fois il ya des choses qui ont
fait qu'on a perdu même montrent les
derniers je crois on a perdu contre les
avant derniers on vous a gagné contre
tous les premiers c'est ça c'est ça
c'est le paradoxe vous auriez pu monter
dès cette saison président à votre avis
alors sportivement il ya aucun problème
nous avions vraiment un effectif et une
équipe pour monter
c'était plus délicat au plan économique
c'est vrai mais on aurait on n'aurait
pas craché dans la soupe et on aurait
assumé financièrement si si on avez si
on avait eu la première place on serait
on aura à suivre
cependant il faut reconnaître que
revenir d'où nous venons d'une crise
économique extrêmement profonde et ceci
en quatre ans avoir récupéré cette
situation pour arriver maintenant à l'
équilibre
enfin il est vrai que c'était une
période de très lourdes de tension
dont nous commençons à sortir nul doute
doute que cette saison n'ont pas raté je
trouve qu'elle est tout à fait réussie
même si ça n'est pas au niveau des
résultats sportifs quels jeunes alors
espérer je comprends aussi bien sûr mais
ça prépare bien et ça inaugure très très
bien de notre saison prochaine d'autant
plus que les moyens on travaille
justement à leur diversification et leur
augmentation
au delà de ce que l'on que l'on dont on
bénéficie aujourd'hui et que je pense
que on sera vraiment prêt non pas pour
gagner mais pour bien réussir en
nationale 2 les prochaines donc avec ou
sans le coach steed tchicamboud qui
était votre coach cette année est ce qui
vous a aidé à progresser un je le
rappelle il a joué notamment chalon sur
saône à nancy limoges one paris
levallois il a remporté une médaille aux
championnats d'europe en 2011
est-ce qui vous a aidé à mieux jouer
cette saison c'est sûr que les venues
avec un énorme bagage avec lui et
c'était d'ailleurs son objectif
principal dans le vestiaire à la fin du
match samedi il a il était surtout
satisfait de l'évolution de chacun et
d'avoir pu apporter chacun chaque joueur
a progressé durant toute la saison
c'est ce qu'il a fait c'est c'est très
fort il restera président s'il fed tient
qu'à nous c'est absolument certain ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas donné son
accord mais j'avais discuté
ah oui oui oui c'est vrai j'ai discuté
et nous sommes tout à fait favorables
non pas de deux
j'ai deux d'essayer à nouveau nom de
continuer cette cette expérience
quelques blocks pour l'instant rien rien
non il est d'accord pour l'instant ouais
du côté des joueurs
vous serez prêt rouge à mieux videmment
revenus c'est presque un ami maintenant
vous allez discuter avec lui il sera au
club la saison prochaine ça non 5 pour
l'instant on n'a pas parlé vraiment
clairement pas pour l'instant
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau continuera à vous suivre la
saison prochaine avec pourquoi pas une
montée dans un an et surtout avec un
steed tchicamboud à la tête de l'équipe
c'est une tradition un saint rémy les
chevreuse pour la 26e année consécutive
l'agent racines étaient organise samedi
et dimanche au départ du domaine saint
paul au programme 9 randonnée en vtt
dont une en nocturne et trois parcours
sur route de type km à 110 kilomètres
dans la vallée de chevreuse un concept
populaire qui attirait plus de quatre
mille cyclistes débutants ou confirmés
on écoute l'un des organisateurs jean
baptiste dufour au micro de notre
journaliste patrick jacques de dixmude
sur cet événement ya pas de chrono il
n'y a pas de pression on peut le voir là
autour de moi c'est des gens qui
discutent autour de tables c'est c'est
pas un événement professionnel on va
être dans un milieu associatif on reste
dans un mur un évènement qui est amateur
mais pour autant derrière proposer
quelque chose de qualité et qui est très
intéressant pour tout le monde
un mot de golf c'est désormais une
tradition dans ce magazine atv 60,18
vous propose une nouvelle fois ce lundi
2 découvrira les plus grands moments qui
ont marqué l'histoire de la ryder cup le
rendez-vous de golf le plus médiatisé au
monde qui sont organisées en septembre
prochain à saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui la golfeuse professionnelle
alexandra bonetti vous présente l'un de
ses meilleurs souvenirs de la
compétition regardez
[Musique]
en 2014 à gleneagles en écosse je les
choisis aussi parce qu'il y avait du
buisson et moi j'avais jamais vu une
ryder cup avec un français de danger
toucher le trophée thomas levet mais je
n'ai jamais vu jouer en ryder cup donc
avec victor c'était quand même super
sympa et on pourra gagner il ya eu
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de frissons
des chip rentrée de tous les côtés
c'était l'époque avec patrick reed
jordan spis
donc c'était un peu plus près de ma
génération aussi donc c'était ça qui
était sympa et oui et donc les gars
aient joué avec tellement de fierté pour
leur pays ou leur continent ça c'est
dans chaque édition un driver cup là où
il ya le plus de pression à les arènes
le plus rempli et au final c'est là
qu'on a les scénarios les plus
dramatiques
et donc là c'est là cette édition était
plus facilement gagnée par les européens
que deux ans auparavant mais je me
rappelle du dernier coup de jamie
donaldson si je me trompe pas quelqu'un
car les mythes je suivais pas du tout et
qu'il a pendant la raideur comme j'étais
quasiment d'une fan en fait qui avait
fait un coup de fer là
1 m du drapeau absolue
regagner la raideur il avait continué
les simples ensuite il y avait ri delà
qui avait fait son shoot comme ça au
public pour les taquiner puis deux ans
après du coup il y avait une petite
réplique de maccarone mais oui c'est
c'est génial c'est unique comme
expérience sport insolite à présent le
club de badminton des volants
d'elancourt organisé pour la première
fois ce vendredi soir pendant deux
heures une séance découverte de phil
minton le concept ce sport basé sur du
fitness permis de travailler la
coordination et le cardio sur de la
musique tout en appliquant les
déplacements liés au badminton
pour ce rendez vous une trentaine de
sportifs venus principalement du
territoire de 50 ans les mines se sont
inscrites pour l'événement dont 30 % de
licenciés du club
une nouvelle session de fitte minton
sont organisées l'année prochaine pour
les par les volants à del en cours
avant de se quitter deux rendez vous à
noter dans vos agendas handball féminin
à monti le bretonneux son ira défier ce
week-end le club de conflent à
l'occasion de la 18e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 victoire
impérative pour les inimitables qui
occupe toujours la dernière place de n 2
avec deux points de retard sur le
premier non relégable stella sport la
tâche s'annonce difficile conflent est
actuellement 5e du championnat
enfin on termine par un rendez-vous qui
sent la poudre en foot ball trap
affronte ce dimanche les gobelins en
match en retard du championnat de r4 et
une rencontre très importante pour les
deux équipes les trappistes ont qu un
seul petit point d'avancé sur la zone de
relégation alors que les gobelins occupe
pour l'instant la première place du
championnat avec une victoire trappe
s'offrirait une bouffée d'oxygène et
pourrait remonter en milieu de
classement
si vous voulez les supporter la
rencontre est programmée au stade
gilbert h en sac
c'est la fin de cette émission à merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]